mit september 2013 stellt österreich
bereits zum zweiten mal den
stellvertretenden kommandanten der kv
friedenstruppe im kosovo
brigadier magister anton wessely in der
heimat leitet der erfahrene offiziere
die dritte panzergrenadierbrigade als
stellvertretender kommentaren die sind
natürlich vorrangig meine aufgabe den
kommandanten in allen belangen zu
unterstützen
anlassfall bezogen weitere aufgaben zu
übernehmen
aber auch verantwortlich zu zeichnen für
die camp infrastruktur und vor allem für
das training und die ausbildung der
gesamten einsatz eingesetzten force im
hinblick auf erhaltung und ausbau der
fähigkeiten
die herausforderungen sind natürlich die
multi nationalität die fonds besteht aus
mehr als 30 nationen und darüber hinaus
in einem stabilen aber doch ständig
wechselnden umfeld über lange zeit die
qualität und zielorientiertheit aufrecht
zu erhalten
es ist das nunmehr 29 kontinent in
kosovo das sich für den frieden einsetzt
seit ende september 2013 befinden sich
die soldaten und soldatinnen unter dem
kommando von oberst leuten und magister
markus kohl weg im einsatzraum ihm zur
seite steht als stabschef oberstleutnant
matthias lampe das aufgabengebiet der
österreicher betrifft den gesamten
kosovo in prizren im süden befindet sich
das sanitätszentrum der friedenstruppe
hier werden verletzte und kranke
soldaten medizinisch versorgt auch am
gassi wobei stausee im norden des kosovo
sind österreichische soldaten im einsatz
hier befindet sich ein pionier element
des bundesheeres am kasseler straße eine
kleine randgruppe der dom den auftrag
die vordenker setzte infanteriekompanie
zu unterstützen für patronen am see bzw
vor allem aber auch zum übersetzt
betrieb dort sicher zu stellen
an der grenze zu serbien patroullieren
die österreicher in boten gemeinsam mit
soldaten anderer nationen
sie kommen vor allem bei unruhen und zur
verhinderung von schmuggel tätigkeiten
zum einsatz
vor der übergabe vom 28 auf das 29
kontinent fand im beisein von in und
ausländischen ehrengästen die metal
parade statt
diese wird abgehalten um alle soldaten
die hier im einsatz waren mit der neuen
artikel 5 meter in einem feierlichen
rahmen auszuzeichnen die soldaten
bekommen die auszeichnung von ihren
kommandanten persönlich verliehen
die welt
ein bis zweimal pro jahr bekommen die
soldaten einen musikalischen gruß aus
der heimat im rahmen der
truppenbetreuung besuchen musiker den
einsatzraum und treten hier
unentgeltlich auf das bedeutet für uns
soldaten hier sehr sehr viel
zum einen sind es heimatliche klänge die
man ja hier nicht zu allzu oft hört und
zum zweiten ist es eben auch ein mittel
um diese anstrengungen thema ort
vergessen zu lassen für einen kleinen
moment
und für einen kleinen moment wieder zu
hause zu sein und das ist also eher
wenig wichtig dampf ablassen und die
kräfte wieder zu sammeln für den
soldatischen alltag hier im september
war es das skilehrer trio welches in
zwei auftritten in prizren und pristina
das internationale publikum bestehend
aus österreichischen amerikanischen
italienischen deutschen ungarischen und
schweizer soldaten begeisterte zur
sicherstellung der öffentlichen ordnung
und zum wiederaufbau der infrastruktur
befinden sich seit dem jahr 1999 rund
5000 soldaten aus 30 nationen im kosovo
mit rund 400 soldatinnen und soldaten
ist österreich einer der größten
truppensteller